in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Amanda
is here hi Amanda how are you I'm
honored to be here how are you good to
have you I'm better than I deserve
why are you from Dayton Ohio cool and
you're here to do a debt-free screen I
am I love it how much have you paid off
twenty four thousand good for you and
how long did that take 18 months good
and your range of income during that
time during that time about thirty
thousand okay Wow
then you've knocked us out fast yes look
at you what kind of debt was this
student loans ah all yes and what do you
do for a living I am in marketing I do
social media marketing good for you
very good what kind of debt all student
loans you said and we did it in 18
months how long you been on school about
five years now okay what happened 18
months ago that turns you on you got on
fire kiddo
I did well I'm a single mom so I found
your book in my mom's house on her
bookshelf and she kind of told me what
it was about and so I was like all right
this sounds good and I took it home read
like the first two chapters and went to
town okay just went after it yeah yeah
so uh did you do anything special
because these numbers I mean your own
beans and rice your mom must have cooked
for you every night
I I was on beans and rice well I had
some in savings so I took about eight
thousand now and write upset or that
helps right and my son and I actually
lived with my dad so living expenses are
very low oh we're lucky enough that he
lets us stay there rent-free and okay
put the roof over our heads okay and
that enables you to make these numbers
work yeah that's perfect yeah that
changes the equation considerably that
lat any eight thousand dollars okay but
you still had to be very very very
intense
yeah intentional yes very good so what
was this what was the tripping
what was the tripwire that made you just
okay we're going to do this you just
found the book yeah I every one small to
go to my mom's house to grab a book to
read and I found it one day I was like
oh this is kind of cool and just went
for it and as a single parent you kind
of feel like you're never going to get
ahead sometimes you know I'm living at
home with dad and I'm raising this kid
by myself and losing
so starting to read your book really
ignited that hope in me and I just went
to town and did it for my son Oh
how old is he he is seven just turned
something alright very good it's good
motivation absolutely I don't really run
around your ankles they motivate you
yeah yeah and he didn't like it all the
time but we want to happen I don't like
anything
no no I'm Dave right that's part of my
job as a parents make a miserable part
of the time exactly nothing about it
that he's happy that I can say yes to at
when and then yeah
he'll live through this right right very
cool very cool so what's going to be
your biggest thing now that you're dead
for me well I actually kind of part of
my story is that after I became debt
free and saved up my three months fully
funded emergency fund God kind of hadded
me on the shoulder I feel like and I
actually won a significant amount of
money a while from one of those
sweepstakes you enter in your email and
forget about it
out of nowhere they told me I was a
grand prize winner and took the cash and
so it's very very lucky to have that and
so I got myself a new car Wow because
that was a big stress I was worried
about saving up for a car that wasn't a
beater amazing yeah it was pretty
amazing and I was able to open a college
savings account for my son and in a Roth
IRA for myself and things that I never
thought I would be able to do so very
very yeah God definitely gave me a pat
on the back for well you should have
sticking to the plan
thank you proud of you and so my very
cool and you brought some folks with you
who came with you my mom Missy is here
and my grandma Linda Oh my mom went
through Financial Peace University with
me so she was kind of my accountability
partner through this whole thing
so three generations of ladies here yes
to celebrate yeah as it should be I'm
guessing they're pretty proud I think so
that's a good thing that's a good thing
yeah they ought to be they ought to be
proud of you and here's what's
interesting when you got this
Sweepstakes in you actually did smart
stuff with it I tried and not everybody
does yeah I mean you had a plan on yeah
already get your head screwed on
straight that makes all the difference
in the world what kind of car did you
get I got a 2013 Hyundai Sonata just new
to me car yeah a great car yeah be very
reliable for you and that your son yes
very nice good deal what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
commitment you know you lay it all out
so simply the zero-based budget the cash
envelopes the whole deal but you really
have to stay committed through the whole
thing it's very hard especially since my
debt if there wasn't a snowball it was
twenty four thousand in student loans
and that was it and so the commitment I
just really had to stay committed and
see the light at the end of the tunnel
so I think that's the key now it makes
all the difference in the world
and you know I think you stay committed
you know simon Sinek wrote a book called
start with why and when you have a big
enough why you can stay committed and
that seven year old is your why
absolutely you're gonna change your
family tree we're breaking this cycle
right here it ends with me and that
that's your why and you can view can
stay committed then mm-hmm if you have a
big enough thing in your heart it causes
your yo even when stuff yeah we're doing
it even when it's raining yep we're
doing it even when we're tired yep we're
doing it cuz you stick right in there
because you have a reason that's bigger
than the momentary pain absolutely yeah
that's really very good I'm proud of you
good y'all thank you we got a copy of
Chris Hogan's book for you retire
inspired and that's your next chapter in
your story one should be a millionaire
now all right call in on the
millionaires email I will and I continue
to grow your career so you can do that
you're on your way you know what to do
and you're doing it and very very well
done thanks all right Amanda from Dayton
Ohio $24,000 paid off in 18 months
making 30,000 a year counted down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one we
got
I love it love it love it love it single
mom making $30,000 a year can pay off
twenty four thousand dollars you can get
out of debt none of you watching or
listening to that have anything to whine
about just shut up if Amanda can do it
she just she just she just did a mic
drop right there man I mean you can do
this stuff she's inspiring very very
cool you know some of you always are
like you're looking for an excuse what
Dave I mean people calling in they're
the people that didn't get free screams
I'll make 100 thousand under no they
don't some of them make a hundred
thousand dollars a year
but some of them make thirty thirty
several times this week make forty they
just decided they were going to be
different you can always look for an
excuse to not win if you want to be a
victim just don't be a victim you can be
there's lots of people in this country
will tell you how to be a victim and
they're happy when you're a victim and
they'll be a victim with you and they'll
give you victim language to use but then
you don't get to be Amanda did you hear
her voice wow stuff going on man stuff
going on changes everything you've got
to believe you can win and then take the
steps to cause that belief to turn into
reality it's not rocket science I know
some of you are like lanolin she's
supposed to be thinking stuff no it is
positive thinking but I mean it's I'm
positive you can do it that's all it is
it's not like it's magical or something
it's not magical but it is magical in
the sense that you can't do it if you
believe you can't what is the old saying
if you think you can or you think you
can't you're right if you think you can
or you think you can't you're right is
it hard
well yeah welcome to grown-up land do
you think this was going to be skittles
rainbows and unicorns come on where do
you think this was going to be I'm sorry
oh it's harsh
out here on when but you can do it you
can do if you don't Center and suck your
thumb wine and blame everybody else you
can do it you're not a victim the
society is not ganged up on you you're
not trapped and you're not stuck will
debut yeah I know you can come up with
an excuse if you want to come up with an
excuse go ahead be a victim if you want
to but I like hanging out with Victor's
people like Amanda she just declared
victory did you hear it I'm dead free
did you hear it I heard it that's a
victory screen right there man this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]